on Tuesday of this week there was a
hearing the Senate Homeland Security
Committee they they brought in let's he
was executive Associate Director for ice
Matthew al bents and Acting Deputy
Commissioner for Customs and Border
Protection Robert Perez where they asked
them about the Trump administration's
indefinite detention basically of
migrant children and they asked them
about the psychological effects that
this kind of detention would have on the
kids their response was absolutely
discussing here it is Peters referenced
the American Academy of Pediatrics it
strongly opposes long-term detention of
children a march 2017 report from the
Academy notes that such dissent
detention and this is a quote can cause
psychological trauma and induced
long-term mental health risks for
children close quote the report goes on
to say that detaining children can lead
to physical and emotional symptoms such
as post-traumatic stress disorder
suicidal ideation behavioral problems
and difficulty functioning in school I'm
gonna ask both mr. elements and mr.
Perez just to clarify your answer to
center Peters are you aware of that
report from the American Academy of
Pediatrics first mr. Albans if I could
just clarify we don't have indefinite
detention I want my question is are you
aware of that report from the American
Academy of kink I've seen media reports
on that report so he says I think I've
seen media reports on that thing the
other guy actually said he wasn't aware
didn't know it existed
had no idea something like that could
happen so I honest to god don't know
which is worse the guy who says yeah I
knew about it or the guy who says no I
had no idea either one of those is an
equally unacceptable answer for what's
happening with this administration and
to go back to al Vince's point we don't
have indefinite detention
well the Flores settlement says you
don't have a in
definite detention you can only hold
them for twenty days by themselves then
you have to reunite them that's true
however a week ago this administration
filed a new rule that has yet to be put
into effect and it's got to be approved
by the courts which probably won't
happen but it basically scrapped the
entire Flores settlement from 1997 they
want to indefinitely detain children
they filed the rule to do it so for him
to sit there and say we don't have that
is an absolute lie because the
administration that he works for just
tried to get it done furthermore we know
that they're actually tripling the size
of at least one child detention facility
right outside of El Paso Texas and we
know that the contracts that they gave
out from the federal government for
these private companies to come in and
build and maintain and staff these
detention facilities those run for the
next four years
you don't up the size of your child
prisons you don't give somebody a
contract to run it for four years if
you're not planning on using it and I
think that's a part of the story too
many people have misses that contractor
angle some contractors have a six year
contract to build more of these
detention facilities yeah Trump
announced earlier in the summer he was
going to stop the family separation we
find out now today an additional 1500
migrant children have been lost or
missed place they're not ending it
they're not pulling it back they're not
scaling it back they're not stopping it
they're still doing it today they plan
on still doing it tomorrow
and if long as long as this man is in
office they're gonna keep doing it until
they get told by the Supreme Court that
they can you can follow me on twitter at
baron balanced you can also find me on
youtube youtube.com slash the Ring of
Fire I am fair and Cousins and for David
Pakman we'll be right back I'm pleased
to tell you that today's show is
underwritten by better help.com / Pakman
therapy is a
horton we have a real crisis in our
country not just people who could
benefit from mental health services but
the stigma that surrounds mental health
services and as many people in the
audience know lots of people in my
family work in the field of mental
health and I have made it a mission of
the show to at any opportunity make
clear that there is absolutely no shame
whatsoever in going to talk to someone
when you feel that that's the right
thing to do and that's what better help
provides you get a fully licensed and
experienced psychologists and therapists
through videophone and text it's less
expensive than meeting in person with a
counselor after three months the price
goes down even more but you get the same
professional service that you would from
going into somebody's office and you
also get unlimited access you can speak
to a counselor every day if you want
signing up is easy you go to better help
calm slash Pakman fill out a
questionnaire they will pair you with a
therapist that works for you but you're
always able to switch to somebody else
if there's a better fit available go to
better help calm slash Pakman it's so
easy to sign up and get started we're
putting a link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube it is
better help calm a /pa que ma n